ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
das ist ein schrecklicher tag für das
land rheinland pfalz für unseren
mitbürgern mitbürger ich glaube das ist
nach der schrecklichen rammstein
katastrophe es weiter mal dass menschen
in dem maße mitfühlen mitgenommen sind
weil es in gewalt ereignis gegeben hat
dass jedem und jeder nahe geht und ich
bin seit 14 jahren im innenministerium
und habe so eine situation auch noch
nicht miterleben müssen
der op hat es gesagt erlaube mir
ministerpräsidentin ich wir sind
unmittelbar dann hier haben den ort des
geschehens gekommen und wir waren
natürlich bei den rettungskräften bei
den einsatzkräften am dom an der porta
nigra
wir haben uns auch aus der distanz die
situation des geschehens angeschaut und
man muss ja allein an den abgelaufenen
ereignissen sehen zickzacklinien waren
gezielt menschen zu suchen um ihnen leid
zuzufügen
und das ist in einem ganz ganz schlimmen
maße geschehen
wir haben vier todesopfer wir haben vier
schwerstverletzte wir haben fünf weitere
erheblich verletzte menschen und sechs
leichtverletzte und hinzu kommen mehr
als zwei dutzend menschen die
traumatisiert sind also das ist ein ganz
ganz schreckliches ereignis
ja die frau bundeskanzlerin frau merkel
hat unmittelbar die ministerpräsidentin
angerufen bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer hat mit mir telefoniert und ich
glaube dieses ereignis erschüttert ganz
deutschland und ich will auch an der
stelle ein herzliches wort des dankes
sagen es sind so viele menschen sofort
als helfer dagestanden menschen die
unmittelbar
an der an den stellen des jeweiligen
unglücks gewesen sind als passanten dann
unglaublich schnell die einsatzkräfte
wir hatten rund 300 einsatzkräfte der
rettungsdienste der feuerwehren thw im
einsatz und über 450 polizeibeamte
austria aus dem bereich des gesamten
polizeipräsidiums wir haben es sehr
schnell die spezial kräfte
zusammengezogen weil es galt trier zu
sichern war zu diesem zeitpunkt
natürlich nicht klar war wie sich eine
solche lage entwickeln kann
die bundespolizei war mit dabei die
wasserschutzpolizei und ich finde es ist
bei all diesen schrecklichen umständen
ein gutes signal dass nach der
alarmierung bei der polizei binnen vier
minuten der täter festgenommen werden
konnte und damit sicherheit gewährt
werden konnte dafür sage ich auch noch
mal ein herzliches dankeschön
wir haben eine situation dass wir davon
ausgehen müssen
ich nehme an die staatsanwaltschaft sagt
dass er gleich mal etwas genauer das
dass ein täter aus der region ist mit
einem deutschen hintergrund und wir
sehen jetzt schon im netz dass es auch
dort wieder spekulationen gilt gibt die
hier keiner bestätigen wird ganz im
gegenteil wir haben klares bild von dem
verdächtigen
deswegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren die die schon mal sagen die
ministerpräsidentin die landesregierung
ich als zuständiger innenminister wir
alle der opfer beauftragter platzeck wir
alle versuchen natürlich an der seite
der menschen zu stehen mit ihnen zu
fühlen mit ihnen zu leiden
die ihre liebsten verloren haben oder
deren angehörige verletzt oder gar
schwer verletzt sind
natürlich werden wir auch in ganz
rheinland pfalz die fahnen auf halbmast
setzen weil ich glaube das ganze land
ist mitgenommen und die weiteren punkte
soweit man konkretisieren kann bitte ich
die staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei
dann auszuführen